[Music]
foreign
about making the first movie was with as
much respect for the cultures that we
were pulling from
we wanted to do the same thing
for the cultures that we were reflecting
in this
excited about the new car
for me it's a dream I've never imagined
playing this character
wakanda itself is such a concept we
really wanted to come back to it and
groom it Ruth just took it up a notch
she will exhaust every possibility to
build this world I know so much more who
I am when I put the costumes on
[Music]
you would take an audience on a journey
you got to grab them by the heart
[Music]
you see the themes of Family Protection
love there's so much that's happening
hopefully you see some men and it speaks
to you personally
[Music]
you've got to keep inspiring people and
I'm praying that that will be the result
of this movie
assembled the making of wakanda forever
and black panther wakanda forever now
streaming only on Disney Plus